je ne
michel une femme une voix un projet
artistique et bientôt sur la scène du
scarabée à la verrière artistes
illinoise en compétition le vendredi 17
mai pour les envols du scarabée michel
se prépare avec audrey son coach vocal
et scénique m'apporte énormément au
niveau vocal puisque avec lg ça fait un
an et demi maintenant que je suis c'est
court donc j'ai je pensais pas mal
progressé face à elle mais là ce que
j'attends d'elle c'est plus
effectivement un coaching scénique pour
avoir une vraie cohésion au niveau du
groupe pour que moi je puisse être plus
au delà du champ dans l'interprétation
en fait de chacun des textes puisque les
textes que j'écris sont assez fort et je
voudrais vraiment que la mise en scène
soit service en fait des chansons à quel
moment tu passes du côté long terme au
collège et
vous rendrez le coach est le miroir de
l'artiste sont drôles et de
l'accompagner pour optimiser l'harmonie
entre ses textes la mise en scène et son
interprétation
l'artiste arrive avec son projet là par
exemple elle va commencer à faire les
morceaux par exemple si on travaille sur
toute seule elle fait le morceau qu'elle
a choisi donc je la laisse faire et je
vais regarder un peu cette comment il va
tourner là je vais commencer à poser des
questions
à voir pourquoi telle chose pourquoi
elle a procédé comme ça ici tout est
dedans
tandis d'âge ce nouveau tremplin de la
chanson française et surtout pour michel
une occasion de rencontres avec le
public
j'ai commencé à écrire des poèmes et
puis après c'était des chansons et puis
bon j'avais plutôt un brin de voix à peu
près intéressant donc qui me permettait
effectivement d'interpréter mais mes
propres compositions et puis j'ai
rencontré
donc audrey qui m'a permis de monter sur
scène pour la première fois et ça a été
une expérience toujours blairer pas bloc
était très forte pour moi avec cette
impression un peu décollé et puis des
transfusions avec les genres en phase
donc c'est voilà j'aspire cassard
maintenant ma particularité c'est de
proposer la chanson française avec plein
de couleurs donc ça passe du swing au
reggae ont fait du blues ont fait la
valse créole on fait du rock voilà donc
il ya plein plein de couleurs
différentes michel écrit et compose ses
chansons des textes empreints d'émotion
qui oscille entre fragilité et puissance
elle évoque son histoire est peut-être
un peu la nôtre
en
dix ans
voilà
rien